my name is john fultz
i'm director of user face technology at
wolf research
and i'm giving a talk that i give pretty
much
annually about the state of the front
end uh
and what we're doing this what we've
been up to and what we're doing this
year
and i hope that uh
i hope that this is enlightening for you
uh it's a boring title
because i got tired of coming up with
titles so there it is
front end 2020. guess what i already
know what my title is for next year
so i have a lot to get through so let's
go ahead and get started
so first of all some ground rules
uh i'm not going to take questions
during this talk i'm expecting to run
pretty close to time i don't actually
know exactly how close but
uh um but i am going to have an ama
that starts a half hour after this ends
10 a.m uh central daylight time and so
if you have questions make a note of
them ask me then
and i'll be there for half an hour also
the entire front end team uh
will be available to have
discussions questions whatever you like
uh grief sessions if that's if that's
what you need to do
uh and that will be 2 30 central
daylight time that's all on the calendar
if i find myself running low on time i
might skip
slides but don't worry i will show a qr
code
at the end that links to this notebook
in the wolf and cloud
if you really want to be able to to
catch it you might pull out your
uh your cell phone camera and be ready
to catch that qr code at the end
the my talk is broken out
roughly into four sections i'm going to
talk about new stuff we've added to
user interfaces new constructs
which are available for you to build
your own user interfaces
and visualizations i'm going to talk
about
uh some of what we're doing with our
updated platform support
um and then i'm going to spend a little
bit of time looking beyond 12.2
it's actually interesting because we
spent a lot of time
doing foundational stuff that
that didn't deliver
into a fully
finished curated
polished feature for 12 2 but
we see the trajectory we have something
that's beginning to work now
and i expect that we'll be shipping the
version after 12
2. it's 13.
the version after 12 2 sometime in the
first half
next year is my thinking we'll see how
that goes
but hopefully well before this
conference next year so why not talk
about it a bit
okay so let's go
uh okay so first of all i would like to
talk about a new thing we added called
canvas
so what is a canvas canvas
is a thing that you draw on so i'm just
evaluating canvas bracket bracket gives
me this frame
okay and so what happens when i click on
the frame
i get some drawing tools now we've had
drawing tools before
they were not the friendliest
tools to use and we worked
uh quite hard on trying to make
something that is
uh that's more focused uh and
and also that is is more straightforward
to use
so we have you know we have all of your
standards sorts of things we have
you know shapes in your shape library
and
being able to set styles quite easily
oops uh
being able to set the dashing and
thickness and so on
uh and so this is uh
uh and we can do uh line
and that's uh you know that's an arrow
but look that doesn't look very good
because i made it a thick line but let's
uh uh can we play with it uh
look at that we can uh well we can add a
head now we got multiple heads
and now we can uh we can we can actually
customize these has
ads as well make them different sizes
um and so i was having a little bit of
difficulty with that version oh yes and
that's my warning that uh
um the hopefully that's
my one for today um
yes i knew a possibility that we might
be getting a crash here
so let's go ahead and
get right back into it um okay
um and i knew that was risky when i did
it so
uh okay uh
you can wrap canvas around something so
we looked at the zero argument form
and now we have uh the ability to wrap
it around something and so
uh so now we can
uh we can do the same thing that we did
before
of course you know point your arrow or
whatever
uh but we can also select parts of the
scene
and so here i'm selecting the plot and
maybe i don't like the color that it
came through you know i want
i want a different color i want to
make it dashed or something like that uh
and there we go i've made these changes
and now i'd like something that doesn't
have
the frame something that uh
that i can just deploy so now
i can wrap normal around it and there we
go
now no drawing tools this is just a
graphic
and so that's the thing that you can do
uh
this allows you to edit your graphics in
place
maybe you didn't really want to edit the
graphic
maybe there's a lot of ink in the
background that you're dealing with
you know and you don't really want to
edit the graphic per se you just want to
annotate the graphic well so that's an
option as well
uh and you can specify
a background option and this this might
come out the wrong size but if it does
we can fix it real quick
um yeah so this is this is a
thing that's just being developed right
here at the end
so just fix that up there we go uh
and so yeah so now we have something
where i can click click click click
click and i cannot i cannot get to that
graphic i can't hit anything in the
background i can still annotate on top
of it just fine
but but the graphic itself
is frozen so
you don't have to do that with just
graphic though
background can be anything so
here i have an expression and well this
is something that we've wanted to do
right
uh that we want to be able to uh
take advantage of well we have a program
that can
represent math nicely well um
why don't we uh why don't we actually
try to
illustrate for example uh the uh
illustrate how the multiplication is
being done
um and we'll set that guy to a different
color
and so we can see the two x's and the
two y's being multiplied
and uh and there we can do
our sort of illustration there and this
is this had nothing to do with graphic
um how is this done this is actually
implemented as an overlay overlay is a
is a function which has been around in
wolf language for a long time
and we can do the same sort of thing
with normal here
uh and the resulting oops look at that
that's okay we'll fix that but uh but
the resulting thing will be an overlay
so that's canvas
noah hardwick is going to be talking
about
canvas and drawing tools and i neglected
to catch
exactly what time it was
but look at your schedule noah is going
to be talking about that
if you're interested okay up next
uh in the user interface section so
uh we have uh completely redone the
uh the open save dialogue for the cloud
um and you can see here the the
what the old version looks looks like
just as a reminder and new version let
me bring that
up real quick just so you can take a
look at it while
i'm talking about it uh and so the
uh the big things here
um so we have an interface that's
providing a lot more information
uh and it's it's working more quickly as
well
one of the things that was a problem and
we had some
people internally who had a big problem
with this actually
um was that uh uh was that the
uh if they had directories that had
hundreds or
maybe even thousands of files that that
the
the old browsing dialogue would just
just plod through and take forever to
update and now we have something that
updates
incrementally uh as needed so
uh we spent a lot of effort on that and
also supports all the special locations
that
you see in the web browser but you
hadn't seen before
uh in in the open dialogue your
favorites i don't have any favorites
because
i don't play favorites but i do have
reasons um
uh and i do have unnamed and i do have
some other stuff so all these categories
work
i have a few yeah there we go so
um so that is
open and save from wolf and cloud
next hyperlinks
so we've had hyperlinks before working
on improving the interface
uh and so so we
have auto linking
which is just linking as you type no
this doesn't affect your code
we're just talking about regular text
cells here
but if you type in something
that looks like a url it will
automatically link up and
or it could be you know some other kind
of of uri as well so
that works too if you have a locally
configured
mail client that would open up in your
mail client
uh and then also uh contextual hyperlink
interface um i need to bail to
another notebook to demo this because i
was seeing a conflict with
the presenter tools notebook here but
and let me just zoom this up a bit
so you can see it but
so if i make some text here
and then i'm just going to
give myself destination
and i'm going to set a and this is off
screen sorry about that
i'm going to set a cell tag on it and so
uh here we have
make hyperlink i can go to a web
location in this case i'll actually
choose to go to a cell tag in this
notebook instead
and it's showing me i only have one cell
tag in this notebook so
there it is apply boom got my hyperlink
uh and then if i click on it indeed
there it is
uh now if i want to go back and change
things i can just go back
and edit the hyperlink again like that
or
actually when you float you'll see this
you know the the little linky linky
thing that you can click on
same thing uh and you can edit it or you
can just remove it entirely
by the way if you don't like the uh um
the
auto hyperlinks you can edit them to
remove them as well
so um the uh there
will be an option to turn it off
everywhere but if it's just like one or
two that you want to turn off being able
to remove it manually is a good option
okay so that's hyperlinks
self-contained usage messages this is
one of my favorites
um so here's the idea
um think about this so
i pulled here a snippet of the
documentation for range
a range has three documented usages
okay has the one argument usage has
two argument usage and a three argument
usage straightforward enough
so now if we if we type
somewhere uh and i
let me do this in in my other notebook
here so if i type
range opens open square bracket
where did um probably because i'm
yeah okay so and i press down arrow here
and i get
the same three so yeah this makes sense
you know so i get these three
and i can choose and you know if i want
the three argument form you know i can
do that
uh but what's interesting about this
though is that the uh
is that when i'm looking at this this
third guy here doesn't make any sense
on its own it really doesn't
range of i'm in imaxdi uses step di
imagine that i just put my hand over the
other two
and you were just looking at this and
what would you think
you'd think i don't have enough
information
but um well sometimes you have
usage messages or you you have
more than three cases a partition
has with 9 or 10 or 50 or i don't know
what it is now but
uh but partition is is always kind of
the
the whipping boy for this but not just
partition others as well
uh have this issue and
uh and and when you're getting some
completion
or look up or something like that it
would be good
to see something that's just relevant
for what you're doing
well so we've started doing something
about this and
it's this is a feature that it's
seen the light of day in wolfram alpha
notebook edition
and so the idea here is that this isn't
something that we could do
automatically we really have to do it by
hand you know we have to go through
and and look at the usage messages and
say hmm
this one doesn't make sense by itself
let's do something about that let's
rewrite it so that it does make sense
uh and so let me just
um let me just
i have to do the secret sauce here in
order to enable it it will be on by
default but it's not
on in the by default yet in the build
that i have and let me copy this
um
okay and file new
wolf alpha mode notebook and we're going
to paste in
0-20 in steps of 3. and this is going to
produce a three argument range
and so uh so here we go
let me
[Music]
okay so there's my three argument range
and now i got a little wolfie icon here
uh next uh
so i mean this this code was generated
by uh wolfman alpha so this is you know
as a user i may or may not know
something about what's going on here
and uh and the idea is let's uh
let's try to help people learn the
language if that's what they want to do
if they want to use it like this and
it's working for them
great no problem but if they want to try
to learn the language let's get an
opportunity so click on it
and you see one not three
one usage message and it's a useless
message and
sorry the magnification is a little
small here but
uh it's a usage message which makes
sense for the specific
form of range that was used here uh and
that's one of the clever bits about it
is uh these uh
uh use messages they're auto-detected
based on
which version of the function you
actually used
so uh and i am
i am really hoping that that is the
beginning of something that we can do
more generally in the product but in
12.2 you're definitely going to see it
in wolfman alpha
notebook edition and in wolf and alpha
notebooks which can be accessed from any
of the other
uh any of the other front ends as well
okay uh tech math mode input i'm not
going to dwell too much on this steven
showed it
if you're interested you you probably
love the idea
maybe you might quibble with the choice
of fonts it's still uh
uh it still fits within our uh
within our general style framework
but that's a conversation we can have i
have all kinds of people who reach out
to me
about uh you know tech and tech type
setting
and how it works and and let me just go
ahead and
paste it in here and there we go i can
go back
and i can click on it and and edit it
maybe maybe maybe
um or it might go
boom um huh
that would nope no no it's just killing
the kernel
okay well uh we can probably deal with
that
yes we can deal with that okay but uh
yeah
so that's uh uh so that is
and i i knew that was a danger point too
because this is
not working as well in the presenter
notebook
but yes so that's uh you can put it in
type setting in the context of text
just to make as steven
said over and over again meaningless
math um
i think it probably has meaning to
someone but we get the point
um or you can try to
evaluate it um it may not evaluate
uh tech you know doesn't have
a strong mathematical semantics
um we so we apply heuristics they
sometimes work they sometimes don't
okay on to the user interface
construction
okay so i'd like to talk about attached
cells
uh we've had attached cells for well
first of all
let me talk about cells so cells can be
nested within cells if you don't know
that many of you probably do
but if you don't know that it's cells
aren't just the top-level constructs but
they can be nested
uh and uh and a few versions ago
we decided to do something additional we
decided to
have uh have cells which were attached
to other things on the screen uh cells
on top of cells
uh and so we've been doing this for a
little while
um so what's new we'll get there in a
second but i have to give some
background
okay so uh you know the idea you know we
have the image toolbar which which pops
up and
gives you useful information we have
another image toolbar
for uh for 3d here which pops up and
allows you to do
cool things like like clipping that guy
uh that's fun we have the predictive
interface
and i'm sure that you have seen that
but i just want to point it out in a bit
of context here
um so here's predictive interface that
is an attached cell
now in this case it's it's a bit of a
strange one because it is uh
it actually pushed the other contents
down but it is an attached cell
if i hit the close button that's also an
attached cell it's a different attached
cell one went away it was replaced by
the other
um so um the
uh we were looking at canvas the drawing
tools in canvas
that's an attached cell um other there
are other
lots of other places some of which are
really not
obvious um for example um
you might have never guessed uh this uh
you know the testing notebook file new
programmatic notebooks testing notebook
and uh
make a test uh those labels there the
the input
expected output those are attached cells
uh
you know it was kind of difficult to get
things to place and and and get the
the pointer behavior or the you know the
mouse behavior and such that we wanted
otherwise so
uh so that's uh that's what we did so
one little bit of trivia but this is
what we did
before our goal was always
to uh make it available to you and now
it is
in a function called attach cell
and see
there we go okay so quick example
now lou d'andrea is going to talk about
this later today i think 12 30
uh but i'm just going to give a quick
example so
so i'm just defining a cell object which
is actually pointing to this cell right
here the cell i just evaluated
i'm going to attach something to it
there it is there's my attachment
it's boring but it returns another
object which represents the attachments
now this attachment doesn't affect what
goes to disk if i
save the file to disk nothing has
changed
um now and and you know
nope you know so if you look at the cell
here this is this is
there's no fish in here uh this is just
the cell as it originally was uh but uh
i still have that object on the
attachment i can
i can mess with it some uh there we go
make us background orange
uh notebook delete we'll get rid of it
um the
uh so here's a fun little example uh
let me put that more towards center of
the screen so you can see it uh
watch the cell bracket on the right here
uh so i'm gonna evaluate this
and that's uh that's kind of a little
progress meter that uh
sticks out of uh of the of the cell
bracket there
um so that's a simple example uh
obviously we've done some very
interesting things i think that
you'll be able to as well okay uh
attached cells can they can have
controls including input fields
uh so that means you can click in them
you can't edit and attach cell unless
you're editing inside the input field
though
uh they're deployed otherwise uh an
attached cell can be attached to a box
to a cell to a cell bracket or even two
parts of the window itself
um mostly it will scroll with the
contents but if you attach it to the
window it doesn't scroll
just stays there uh you can set an
attachment point
uh and in fact this is sort of the
default thing to the perimeter of an
object so you don't have to measure
uh the object to try to figure out oh i
have a i have a
you know a thing which represents a disk
how big is that disk you don't have to
worry about that figures it out
automatically uh and you can track
conditions for self deletion like losing
focus
typing clicking somewhere okay lou
d'andrea 10 30.
uh i'm going to speed through a few
things here um
the table view table view has gotten a
lot of love in
in 12-2 and it's going to continue to
get love going into
13. um so the uh
uh here's some stuff about table view
um uh jason abernathy is giving a talk
at noon daylight central daylight time
so
go see that um shaders
uh so here um i'm uh kind of
revealing just a bit of you to lose talk
yusu's talk is immediately after this
he doesn't know that i'm spoiling his
talk so don't tell him
um so um shaders
i just gave a little bit of background
here we've been doing some shader stuff
hatch filling tune shading you know
there's several other fillings and
shadings
uh we have some new ones uh and i'm kind
of a fan of
these um so um
the uh yeah the basically linear
uh con iconic and radial filling now
this
of course looks pretty simple but uh but
these things can
fill anything so we have a filling here
uh we have
we have something that did work honestly
um but not now um
the uh because something
has uh uh there we go
there we go yes okay um yeah
so that's uh uh so that's
the the various fillings um and oh and i
like the radial gradient filling on the
complicated polygon there
um template box jason harris
spoke about template box i i think these
talks are being recorded so
uh so uh pay attention to his talk um
the uh um uh the big
thing that um i i talk a little bit
just about history of template box i
don't have time to go too much into that
but here is the thing that i've been
wanting to do for ages
take a look at this so this is uh this
control
by the way uh so this is a you know i
can i can change this color to be
something else but
uh look at all of the stuff that that's
there
we've we've hard-coded a button and a
tool tip
and a graphic and uh uh you know frame
ticks none
and all kinds of things that gosh i just
i just wish we didn't you know
uh image size is dynamic of something
something something
what if so in some future version we
want it to be a different size
you know that's it's hard-coded that's
it it's done you saved it the notebook
it's done
um so here
is what we can do today uh and we're not
changing the default type setting
because
quite yet because we want to wait for
compatibility but here's what we're
doing today
and take a look at this same thing
but it's all stored in the style sheets
so uh
works in the same way everything's good
okay
uh platforms um so
you have questions about our max yes
we're actively working on an arm port
we're also working on testing uh the
12-2 intel version under rosetta we've
been looking at 12-1 as well
uh the 12-2 story will be a bit better
than 12-1 we
think but you know the final product
isn't out uh
but you can bet that we're on it um
so something which we'd hoped to deliver
for 12.2 didn't quite make it it's
definitely going to make it for 13
is uh a complete uh uh rewrite
of the uh of the 2d rendering system
um fonts in 2d drawing and windows
um and so that that will be the release
after 12 to
13. and
uh we have uh so we have a single
renderer
um for uh for desktop and mobile
uh and guess what we compiled it for the
web and it emits webgl
um and it's not in the uh
uh the web platform yet but it's on a
path to get there and this is really
exciting
it's uh when we have one source code
base we can make sure everything works
the same way so that's really exciting
stuff
okay uh coming soon james lane is giving
a talk at 10 30
about axes uh well not just about axes
he's giving talk about a couple things
actually also my next bullet point here
but um the uh so this is fun
axes um not this is this is in the lab
this isn't
ready for prime time yet but axes
are going to become graphics primitives
and this is something we're going to be
rolling out for that next release
i don't i don't have anything to show
here because ray tracing
is uh um is something that
uh we don't really know how much we
should invest in this
do people care people not care we don't
know
um it's it's it's hard to do we have
something that looks interesting and it
runs on mac os
just mac os definitely experimental
but it will be there in 12-2
for you to play with if you have a mac
version um
it's undocumented unsupported but we'd
like feedback on it
james is going to talk about that and
i can't show you here because i'm on a
windows machine
so thanks james um
okay library link we've spent a lot of
uh
work on this library link is going to be
a thing for the front end as well it's
already a thing for the kernel but it's
going to be a thing for the front end as
well
uh and so why would we want to do that
well it's nice to be able to share
code you know these library link modules
between the kernel front end we can
uh and you know we can imagine things
like for example i'd love to add deep
integration to get into the notebook
interface
uh communicate with the front end
without saturating the
the the the wstb connection between the
kernel the front end
um one nice thing about doing a link is
you can do stuff on a thread and
have you know pretty good isolation you
know between the uh
it's running the same process but you
you have because the way the code is
written you're pretty sure you're not
sharing uh fundamental resources um
one of the one of the motivating
examples here was uh
was it would be nice to build a video
player so i did
um so uh yeah this
is uh um uh something that i was working
on
spent about two days a lot of that was
figuring out how
uh ffmpeg works is it's just a you know
a thing which it's not fancy if this is
a toy
but it's proof of concept uh and so
uh so the um
uh well you know so i mean i made
something
which you know and i downloaded some
movies from uh
from nasa and i made something which
plays a movie yeah
you know what the current video does
that uh so
um so i thought well you know why not
just play
uh all the movies but i thought ah you
know i
there are enough movies full of five by
five grids so here
is you know five by five movies uh
and we'll just uh start some of these
things uh
and i thought you know what i don't know
if you know can the current video player
do this
guess what um being able to play 25
movies
actually the current video player can do
this
uh that's kind of fun um so
so why did i do this then if uh uh
if indeed the uh uh the current video
player is basically doing what i've done
here
well here's one thing that the current
video player can't do
i just quit kernel and uh
um and the movies are still going and
everything is
everything's quite smooth i think the
thing that would be most confused is my
presentation notebook which is why this
was in another notebook
okay so let me finish off here um
oh and down it goes and we were just to
my last slide
or penultimate slide anyway
so let me bring that back up
i guess i pushed it harder
here than i did in uh when i rehearsed
this
so um yeah what were those movie boxes
they were just um you know dynamic wrap
around bytes
which was just data that i was sending
back uh this
much this is a box standard image um
it was just boxes represent an image
with the dynamic module variable
representing the data
that's pretty much all it was and some
dynamic tickling going on between the
library link
that's the interesting thing the dynamic
tinkling tickling
uh and yeah not much more than that
like i said um so
the talk notebook is here uh qr code
by the way cloud publish notebook now
shows you qr codes when you publish
that's where i got this from so
if you have any questions i will be
around at 10 thank you very much for
your time
you